[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
we're in the video
I team welcome to a live stream here on
Facebook live from Google in Mountain
View California
lovely glamorous Mountain View
California in the heart of the Silicon
Valley or if not the heart at least
somewhere behind the ribcage we're gonna
talk today about something that you
probably don't think terribly much about
but should and that's the interaction of
the cloud and science okay this may be
the future of science if you're doing
science this may be your future in any
case I have with me an expert on the
Google cloud and how it interacts with
science let me just tell you a couple of
sentences about myself my name is seth
shostack and I'm a senior astronomer at
the SETI Institute also here in Mountain
View California and our job is to look
for life in space and in particular
whether there's any intelligent life in
space but we're going to talk about that
maybe a little bit later at the moment I
want to introduce our expert mossy oak
Massimo mascara and Massimo tell us a
little bit about yourself nice to meet
everyone yeah
my name is Marcia mascara I'm a
technical director here at Google and
actually I work specifically on apply
day I have a background in physics
actually I was a space nerd and kind of
an aspiring astrophysicist but then I
got into competition neuroscience I got
kind of fulminated by the idea of neural
networks and I started working in AI and
I've been doing that since here at
Google I'm in Google Cloud and what I do
is that I work with some of the largest
Google client helping them applying AI
inside their problems so this is
actually how I came to kind of work on
this project because about in in April
last year we started working with NASA
in particular the frontier development
lab and at that point actually I really
kind of my passion for space kicked in
and I thought I kind of chose to step in
and work with them okay now you talk
about FDL that's the frontier
development lab that's an initiative of
NASA right so how does NASA interact
with the private sector because Google
after all is in the private sector so it
is so FDL is a really really cool
program that NASA runs what I do is that
the seek partnership with basically
private companies to help out on some of
the biggest challenges that nASA has
one of the big themes that FDL kind of
research about and in fact I would say
is is one of the most prominent one is
actually artificial intelligence applied
to NASA's problem so Google give me an
example of a problem for example mean
like one of the things actually that we
work on this year is actually it's a big
problem in artificial intelligences how
do you actually kind of automatically
detect transiting of planets from the
signals that you get from your space
telescopes it is a problem where if you
want machine learning is very very
useful too because right now actually a
lot of Disick's done actually manually
and by batch astronomers and actually do
is actually high error rates in that
okay so in the cloud you have of course
the opportunity for sharing data anybody
can get to it presumably if they're
interested in the problem looking for
planets around other stars just to
follow up on your example they can get
to the data but they can get to
something else there too they can get to
two tools right so they're I think
actually three main things that you can
get actually in the cloud so the first
one of course is the ability to kind of
get a lot of data in and have actually
kind of very very fast access to it this
actually kind of bread and butter and
you have to have that the other thing is
competition so on the cloud you can get
a lot of computation to run on top of
that data and that actually is also very
important and is actually by the way in
science is not like a super easy thing
to do I mean believe it or not I mean
some of the largest supercomputers today
are used for science but actually are
not very available to a lot of scientist
and then the third thing is in cloud
actually we built a series of like
higher-level of things that allow you to
do things from you know analytics and
data processing to you know AI a machine
learning they actually are tools that
you build on top of like these two
layers of data and computation they
allow you to do those kind of things
actually much more easily okay now
suppose all right I'm a research
scientist I kind of know what they look
like right there a lot of them near my
office they're sitting in their cubes or
sitting in their offices whatever and
they're on a desk and in the corner
there's a stack of reprints that only
five people in the world can actually
understand and you know they're working
on a problem maybe that problem isn't
exactly this one right they want to know
are there a lot of planets out there or
they're not a lot of planets out there
okay now in the past they would have to
go get some data themselves right and
they would have sort of exclusive you
that data at least for a while even if
it was from the Hubble telescope er you
know some publicly owned instrument
right and now okay they need to go
through those data and and take a look
is there something interesting in it
they'd write some code themselves right
it would be proprietary you know they
would probably spend half their lives
debugging their own code right and they
would have a limited data set and that's
how they would work yeah now how's that
gonna happen now I mean you know I'm I'm
sitting in my office wondering hey look
how am I gonna beat all those
competitors in so I mean a couple of
things I mean of course like scientific
data very often actually comes from
sources like what you mentioned so for
example I can tell you that in the work
that we've been doing with FTL on
exoplanets we've been working with
Kepler's data that is now actually
public datasets but you know they have
there is a delay because there are
certain research institutions they
usually have exclusiveness on those data
for example if we we haven't worked yet
on the newly kind of test data test is
the new support for those who don't know
Kepler is the old exoplanets or
satellite Oh
it's been dead for what a month a month
but actually you know it's been actually
in space for ten years or more and
intest is that just newly launched I
mean they launch it with SpaceX last
April and and test actually is in orbit
and is collecting data but that data is
not available yet it is available to
NASA into some of this kind of research
scientists but not to kind of to the
public so two things actually there of
course you have to have access to the
data but very very large datasets are
now becoming public and in any case it
is always possible even if you have
private datasets to you know work with
Google and kind of have it important in
a private kind of setup inside the cloud
the cloud doesn't have to be public in
that it's open to everyone if you don't
want to we have a lot of like if you
want commercial customers they have very
very sensitive data that do not share so
that's possible but I would say that the
very exciting thing is when you work on
these public datasets and now actually
you have access to this data but very
often having access to they did I can
download all the Kepler data sets from
NASA today if I want to but the point is
that what I'm going to do with it case
first of all it's not likely not going
to fit inside my computer and even if it
does then actually processing that data
requires very extensive computational
capabilities
I wouldn't have and the cloud allow you
to have those a very very cheap price
now in the work actually with NASA
Google sponsored that so that that was
not an issue but in general even if
somebody had to pay it it's actually you
only need you really pay for what you
use actually Google actually will charge
you by the second literally kind of when
you have a machine if you have it for
one minute and 37 seconds to do a
particular computation that's exactly
what you'll get charged for and so this
actually is it's very transformative I
think in science because now I have
these very large data sets that are
becoming more and more available I have
the ability to kind of spawn with a very
very kind of cheap price very large
competition to analyze that data sets
and I have this whole layer of toolings
that for example army to kind of create
a machine Lerman
or to kind of run a very sophisticated
analysis that before actually would have
been would have required maybe me to get
action times a lot on a very big
supercomputer that may be actually my
department doesn't have access to right
so this really kind of allows everyone
to kind of do this and I would actually
kind of put it even kind of beyond that
there are actual a lot of initiatives
are now around citizenship science my
you know people they are not officially
in scientists kind of starting to do
real science and I think actually this
opens up a lot actually the floodgates
off of that to happen as well well I was
gonna say this sounds like taking
citizen science right to the max I mean
right because now everybody can get to
the data but beyond that everybody has
some you know very competently written
presumably tools to allow them to look
at that data so they can look for
correlations or they presumably they
could say okay what I want to find is
some sort of dip in the brightness of
stars that tells me that that star has
some planets going around whatever it is
can you give me another example of the
kind of things yeah and actually this
actually is another example that we
worked on this summer that is also kind
of opening up another kind of stream of
thought in in the second work we did
with NASA we were working on
astrobiology and and one of the big
problems in astrobiology is okay
assuming there are planets out there now
we know actually that there are many
exoplanets out there outside of our
solar system we want to actually whether
there's life or not the problem of like
knowing whether there's life or not is
to also understand what life is right I
mean there are many many different kinds
of possible life that would be
conceivable and in a sense actually we
only have one sample
is what is on earth so one way around
this is that you could simulate what
life could look like and they're
actually various ways the the thing
actually that we did with we definitely
L this summer was to basically simulate
metabolic pathways so kind of different
combinations of molecules that kind of
bombed
I got a follow up on it you can simulate
what extraterrestrial life might be like
now look I get called up you know every
third week by some producer down in
Hollywood yeah and they're gonna make a
film about how aliens have come to earth
to this story downtown Chicago or
whatever whatever is on their minds and
they want to know what are the aliens
gonna look like that sounds like you've
got the tools to figure that out I mean
surely that's not exactly what you mean
now it's much less glamorous if you want
but actually in a sense actually is also
much more interesting a lot of like what
what we're thinking about life today in
terms of kind of you know you might know
it figures and so on you know I mean we
can actually go there but it's likely
it's actually is going to be very
unlikely the vast majority of life that
we expect to find on you know exoplanets
maybe just kind of you know kind of
unicellular life or may not even seller
may just be kind of some kind of
chemical processes that go on they kind
of signal the fact that there is not
there is actually something that kind of
itself for producing okay so in other
words to begin with
the whole question of what life is I
mean that's a different question right
and there's there's actually no good
answer to that I mean people say well
life reproduces and you know metabolic
processes and all that stuff
uses resources maybe moves around right
but that's true of a lot of physical
phenomena that are not alive like fire
or something like that so in fact it's
it's not that you're trying to define
life you're trying to say what chemical
processes might lead to there's
something that you know has the
characteristics of life right is that it
it is that's actually it's a it's a it's
actually is a restrictive idea of life
right because actually may be many many
larger ways of intending it you know
like life could be completely digital or
it could be actually not even based on
necessary care of chemistry but in the
real mob life that is based on chemistry
one thing that we know at least on earth
the life does is that it changes the
chemical compositions of planets in
particular changes the chemical
position of atmospheres of planets the
reason this is interesting is that we
have a shot at measuring the atmospheres
of some of these exoplanets now to be
clear today we cannot do that yet at
least that's what my NASA friends tell
me but in the near future I mean
apparently the James Webb telescope may
be able to do this we may be able to
detect spectra of some of these
exoplanets okay just to clarify from
people who don't work in this field if
you were to look at earth if you were a
Klingon astronomer right you know I hope
they get paid better than the earthly
fine
but if you were a Klingon an astronomer
and you had a big enough telescope sort
of like James Webb and you looked at the
earth with that thing you might be able
to find that there's oxygen in the
atmosphere you know twenty percent of
the year in this room oxygen right but
that oxygen comes from photosynthesis so
they would say oh I don't know it's
their Zork but you know all that oxygen
there must be you know lettuce or
asparagus or something that does
photosynthesis okay but that might not
be the only indicator maybe they don't
you know breathe out oxygen if they're
they're plants on another planet is that
the idea that yeah so like in the one
thing I want to say for people who are
not kind of in this field is that you
know you could actually say well I mean
couldn't oxygen just kind of be on that
planet for other reasons well we know
that oxygen binds a lot to a lot of like
chemicals so like it's very unlikely
that oxygen stays in the atmosphere for
a long period because it would just
oxidize most of the stuff that is in
that planet and basically mine so
basically disappear from yeah turn all
the iron in this soil to real just like
like Mars
everyone's Russ isn't it's a good
example so the fact that there is action
is because something is actively
producing it now there are various ways
on which oxygen could be actively
produced by known life systems but we
actually have a lot of like metabolic
ways in which this happens and actually
oxygen to your point is not just the
only thing I mean in fact one of the
thing actually they told me the
astrobiologist that we work this this
year is that actually the sense oxygen
is almost like the smoking gun of life
because you know an oxygen level like
the one that we have on earth is oh is
almost unlikely to be actually just kind
of do two geological sources but there
are many other chemical for example just
looking at the ratio of methane and
oxygen or methane and other components
so for their there are a lot of other
chemicals that could actually manifest
signatures of life being on their
friends so but going back to cloud and
kind of what the problem is is that very
often these digital signatures of what
would be the relative components of
these chemicals in atmospheres we only
know them for Earth
right and if you want to know what the
signature will look like for different
kind of reasonable metabolic pathways
you would have to simulate that and this
actually is what we did with with Google
and and one thing again I mean kind of
going back to the initial discussion one
thing that was very useful is the fact
that this immolations are very expensive
computationally and in a sense actually
it would take like years to run those
things on just kind of even very very
fancy hardware that a normal University
has we were able to spin up on Google
cloud thousands of machines in parallel
and basically kind of the bulk of the
data set that was produced was produced
in a matter of a couple of weeks but
just actually spawning action a lot of
like machines inside our data set I
gotta say master because I know somebody
who is a recycle secrets her name she
said MIT and this is her job it's to try
and figure out okay if we can measure
the whatever is in the atmosphere or
some planet around some other star right
can we say that there's life there
there's not life there our people like
that using the Google cloud or they
already using these tools or is this
coming down the pike in the near future
yeah I think actually it's picking up so
I know there are a number of like
research institutes and kind of Science
Institute scientific institutions that
are already using Google cloud and cloud
in general I think actually one of the
thing actually we did in NASA today and
this summer and that section I I'm
really hopeful that kind of creates a
movement is the fact that that we proved
how this can be useful now one kind of
other aspect of the NASA FDL problem a
program to get clear is that it's a
program to last about ten weeks so in
basically there are the scientists that
come and work at actually FDL here in
Mountain View and in ten weeks they just
have to start and end it literally have
to finish their technical reports in ten
weeks and so one other thing I want to
throw in there is that it doesn't
take much this guy's literally arrived
date they had absolutely no knowledge of
Google Cloud at all I remember actually
we had actually a meeting at Google and
like we were basically explaining how to
spin up machines how to kind of train
machine learning models and they were I
mean most of them actually had
absolutely no career experience and and
they weren't actually in ten weeks to
publish some very interesting results
and actually now actually are talking
conferences they're publishing papers on
this alright so what you're saying is
scientists are already doing this or
scientists want to do this you know
they're not gonna has to spend years
learning how to do it right I mean they
can get trained up in a couple of weeks
and and they can start doing something
useful I think so and I think actually
this is transformative because at the
end of the day a lot of like modern
science is it's not anymore just kind of
you know genius people kind of sitting
down with paper and pen and kind of
having like a brilliant idea
it's it's a lot actually has to do with
data analysis with computation with
simulation and I think actually cloud
can be transformative now this actually
still we haven't touched yet even into
the real mouse machine learning and the
ID I think it's also very very
interesting and exciting but one thing
is just actually at the basic of science
I think actually cloud can be very
transformative and I think you know it's
just a matter of sometimes of culture
and kind of being kind of used to a lot
of researchers today do not know yet
these tools that they haven't
experienced them and in a sense actually
I'm pretty sure that as soon as they
kind of get to know them better the
front actually they can change Excel on
how the work let me take another
specific example here in the 1970s a
NASA sent a couple of Landers the Viking
landers to Mars you know looking for a
life on our little ruddy buddy up there
right and the answer they came back with
I mean this cost a lot of money it was
like a million dollars or something I
don't remember exactly but the answer
that came back was don't know you know
we don't think we found any life but of
course we can't be 100% positive
well obviously the space agency wasn't
really happy with this answer and I
suppose the taxpayers to the extent that
they paid attention we're very happy you
are there because you spent all this
money you want to know if there's life
on Mars and comes back maybe right you
don't want that you want a definitive
answer like 42 or you want a definitive
answer now if they had had the Google
Cloud and these tools back in the
mid-1970s do you think they would have
had a better answer in the sense of a
more
Finnick evades I I don't know because
actually that's actually also like
whether the answer was in the data or
not right so what what the cloud cannot
give you is answers that are not in
there that said I think that for a long
time in science we've actually
experienced this idea that you know
people work on a particular problem they
do an experiment let's say you send
action NASA probe or actually sometimes
actually you know like you you do like
an experiment see in a lab you collect a
lot of data you process them and the
best thing which you can and and
actually you publish a paper maybe and
that's it that's the end of that data
right I think actually the idea that
this data section now become public and
these datasets are becoming big and that
people now from all over the scientific
and non-scientific community can go
there and we look at those data it means
that you can now start squeezing tree
much more information out of the same
datasets and actually we can both
validate better
our research result and we can also if
you want find things that actually had
gone undiscovered
I mean case in point Kepler data right
we Kepler has been there for 10 years
and with the help of Kepler nASA has
been able to declare I don't remember
the number but I think actually is north
of 2500 planets exoplanets yeah if I
remember correctly more actually last
year actually Google kind of took that
data set and this is not kind of part of
this FDL this was Google brain and our
AI research department took that data
set and they basically applied machine
learning to it and they didn't discover
a number of exoplanets they had gone
undiscovered fact they discovered an
entire exoplanet system that looks quite
like the earth they have complete gone
undiscovered now I mean on one side is
the ability to have access to the data
so that's very important and I think
actually NASA is doing an excellent job
in making all those data says public and
I think a lot of other institutions and
even kind of university labs should just
kind of follow follow suit and some are
but like even more every data set in my
opinion in science especially if it's
publicly funded should be public but
then that's not sufficient either right
because now I have this gigantic data
set and there is no way if I don't have
access to the nasa supercomputer i can
actually extract information from it so
the idea that now actually as you know
somebody the guy the guys at Google
actually you know
was done actually with an astronomer at
University of Texas if I remember
correctly but so like but the other guy
actually here Google was just an AI
engineer and you know they basically sat
down together says okay let's reanalyze
this and they found exoplanet they got
missing so I think actually this is a
great opportunity for us to extract more
information out of the data sets that
very often costly we collect and
actually to also understand better
what's sometimes actually wrong because
like maybe sometimes actually did the
problem is that an analysis that is
think that actually may be wrong and
like the idea that other people can look
at the data actually makes it much more
verifiable that is actually one of the
principle of science okay you know
they're coming down the pike some really
big telescopes right now we're talking
about astronomy here a lot but now
telescopes that can look at the entire
sky every four days that sort of thing
you know see things that we've never
seen before I mean you know there could
be flashing the lights in the sky we
would never see them because the
telescopes are never looking in the
right place at the right time right so
we're gonna have instruments who can do
that we're also building these huge
telescopes you wouldn't with mirrors
that are 2030 meters across and
obviously they're gonna be able to do
things that our current telescopes can't
so the instrument the instrumentation is
certainly getting a lot better but it
produces enormous tons mountains of data
that nobody can go through anymore this
is not like in the old days you know
when I was a kid just before the Crimean
War when I was a kid you know you you
would go to the telescope you put a
photographic plate at the back end of it
you'd make a photograph and then that
plate would go in your desk drawer
nobody else could get to it nobody else
could look at it and maybe you didn't
ever look right yeah so obviously that's
gonna change it sounds like the
researchers are gonna become data
scientists I think actually more and
more I mean I think actually in part
they already are if you think about how
most of research and most of the
research I have done personally was
really at the border between data
science data analysis and actual kind of
you know trying to in my case actually
was studying computer science I was
trying to understand how the brain works
but it was a lot of like heavy data
analysis but the other aspect is that
you know these data sets to your point
are becoming more and more jagan
gigantic and and they actually they are
more and more
to Rikers I mean some of this telescope
require you to do all sorts of process
into this data and this processing may
sometimes actually kind of change the
data so sometimes you have to do
different kinds of pre-processing this
actually was the case of Kepler for
example and so like the idea that you
have now this vast computation
infrastructure this vast analytic
infrastructure and they're actually we
can talk a little bit about machine
learning as well K I think actually
that's also going to play a huge role
there I think actually that's that's
going to be transformative now one last
thing actually on this point is the fact
that I think more and more we're also
kind of starting to see kind of data
collection happening outside of the real
MA like gigantis kind of instruments
that kind of let's say NASA our s
actually deploys there is an interesting
project that I got kind of to know about
where they actually they're protected
this kind of small telescope these are
kind of almost a motorist telescopes
basically all around the globe to track
this exoplanets and the idea is that you
know Tess actually will only look at a
certain patch of the sky for
twenty-eight days at a time and so like
maybe actually the other telescope will
pick up from that and kind of start
doing this and again these actually
agamous these datasets and becomes
really fundamental now to be able to go
across datasets
not just kind of being able to apply
like the big guns of like supercomputers
or the cloud into a particular datasets
but being able to kind of spawn between
datasets then very often have very
different shapes forms and they need
actually very different kind of
pre-processing and an ability to parse
so like that actually is also kind of
it's going across data sets it's going
to be very transferable I have to have
to say I mean in my line of work when
you're looking for a radio signal or a
light signal coming from et and we get
lots of signals it's not like in the
movies right you're sitting around
looking bored and suddenly you know you
see a spike on a on a screen and
everybody jumps up and starts screaming
and calling up the press and all that
sorry what actually happens is every 10
seconds you get a signal okay
but those signals can be very you know
messy looking right and hey I might be
the just a ticket to sort through those
millions and millions of signals you're
getting every day and decide okay this
is interference from the satellite this
is maybe et this is not et that kind of
thing I mean it you know personally this
sounds like a very attractive thing
we've been talking a lot
about astronomy space research can you
give me another example I'm just
thinking there must be huge data sets
out there which you know talk about
various diseases people who get a
certain kind of cancer and this is you
know maybe their diets or their
lifestyle or something else and nobody
has the ability to see if there's a
slight correlation with maybe eating
broccoli and getting cancer the elbows
or something like that I mean those
those actually are big topics a you may
have heard Google actually is very vast
and into health and kind of you know
we're working a logging it actually very
recently we created a whole division
called Google Health that kind of will
work on those problems some of the early
results in that in their area are kind
of mind-boggling in that it's not only
about the fact that you can now actually
kind of infer across very very large
datasets and understand this is better
is the fact that very often you then
actually get also Danny says they are
much more democratized so to give you an
example one of the work that Google is
doing is to basically understand from
images of the eye of your retina whether
they look at your kind of your your
blood patterns there and actually then
actually can infer actually whether you
have certain kinds of diabetes now this
is transformative because if you can do
this for real and is actually still very
experimental and it's kind of still has
to be a lot verified but if you can
start doing this with a camera on a
smartphone that means that somebody that
is let's say in a poor region of the
world and hasn't accessed like kind of
super good kind of health systems and
doctors we just kind of be able to point
this phone in this eye and kind of know
something very very important about his
health it also of course actually even
kind of in in rich countries where we
have access to health care it means
actually much easier prevention I think
I should that that's gonna change a lot
of things now going back to the problem
again you can do this if you can
actually build systems they're able to
kind of very often understand the minute
kind of very subtle kind of patterns
inside images data set temporal streams
whatnot right and so that's actually
where kind of very often you need to
kind of do very extensive machine
learning on very large data sets because
in order for
to detect those patterns you have to
kind of being be able to kind of
identify the spot I'm seeing two very
large data sets and that's again so this
brings to mind a couple of possibilities
one is the in the diagnosis realm you
know I I'm fortunate I live in you know
here in California and if I don't feel
well I can go to my physician and he's
seen me for years and since I will you
know walk into his office he already has
made some analysis of me because he
knows what I should look like that kind
of thing
but I think it's already the case I mean
there's been some demos of this right
that if you let the AI do the analysis
or the diagnosis that it might be a
little more accurate than the human
position because it doesn't forget all
those rare conditions that the the
physician has because they've never seen
them so there's that and then and then
there's a question of indeed if you're
in a part of the world where you don't
have access to that kind of healthcare
that may be your phone which allows you
to maybe do some of these measurements
send that to the AI and then it
diagnoses you and you get a better level
of health care right again I mean this
is still very early times and it's
actually still very much in the domain
of research and science but I think
actually this is that is that is one of
the transformation that's going to
happen in healthcare i I do agree with
you that very often actually you know
today healthcare I mean while we have
wonderful doctors and you know the
healthcare science actually has improved
as we probably could never have dreamt
even like 20-30 years ago I actually we
know that there are actually a lot of
like differences between doctors I mean
and the fact that the doctor is a human
person a human being is a factor right I
mean you know your doctor may have you
know like himself a health issue the day
before he's visiting you and maybe it's
not actually completely kind of kind of
at his best
or he just actually may have like a
worry cuz I don't know he he son
actually kind of had had an argument
with his son actually did the night
before visiting you and again that's
that's one issue with we're gonna have a
good bedside manner I mean that's a
question I probably get all the time
right I like my doctor because he jokes
around with me right that says yeah but
that's not actually what I'm saying is
that machine learning is completely kind
of distract from this if you have a
machine learning that works it will work
in a very
consistent way so that's that's probably
but of course actually we don't have yet
like kind of elastically kind of machine
learning systems that can even kind of
get close to match current doctors but
that actually is where a lot of research
is going right now because it is gonna
kind of transform completely field now
going back to science I mean the the
part the head of like the doctor kind of
giving you a full diocese being driven
by an AI I think it is actually it's
doing a lot of research into applying AI
to medicine and and see if this kind of
goes into discussion we're having about
science because those guys always come
from like you having kind of churned
through a lot of data and having mesh
whatever kind of di is kind of in this
case predicting or diagnosing with what
you know is true and actually this
requires a lot of work in actual basic
science to start with we're getting some
questions from the viewers okay and
here's one could you explain the usage
of the Google cloud tools in the context
of the NASA frontier development lab for
for its challenges which are in the
fields of EXO and Astro so you might
want to explain what EXO and Astro are
but yes doesn't word the two things
actually we touched on so EXO is our
exoplanet search work with FDL where we
were basically trying to Train
machine learning algorithms that would
detect exoplanets passage into the data
from Kepler and then kind of tests and
asteroids that actually is the
astrobiology work it really was two
streams of work one stream was about
simulating these metabolic pathways to
understand what again life could look
like on these exoplanets and then the
second part was simulating how those
metabolic pathway would affect the
spectrum that you would spectrum as
basically the different colors that you
basically see the different frequencies
of light
did you see actually a slice passes
through the atmosphere and when you
actually have that fan up phenomenon you
can actually detect what kind of
chemicals inside the atmosphere of
course there is a lot that goes on
inside this process and so what is in
the atmosphere doesn't kind of correlate
one-to-one with what those spectrum kind
of look like it's a
Khanh part was kind of really kind of
characterizing this kind of life
signature as basically spectrum of
planets so going to the question the the
the tools actually that we use actually
were kind of very wide Y spanning so on
one side actually we as I said actually
we we had actually all the data kind of
come in to Google cloud we actually we
spawn a lot of competition so a lot of
the simulations have been run inside
Google Cloud we took some very very
sophisticated codes they actually NASA
had developed for for example simulating
atmospheres and we basically kind of
adapted them to run on your cloud and
then we run them as very very large
scales then the second part is that and
those machine learning models actually
have to be built so on the machine
learning side a lot of the researchers
actually use extensively something that
is becoming very very popular in data
science and kind of in general email
research there's the ability to kind of
write notebooks now for those of you who
are not technical a notebook is
basically a document where you can
basically put code and executing it and
you can actually kind of have graphics
kind of beam down inside that document
and so we had actually a system that
would allow our researchers to kind of
spawn their notebooks on site our
infrastructure and that kind of run
machine learning through that also like
Google actually provides a number of
tools to do what is called Server last
training that is you can basically
submit a piece of code to Google Cloud
and basically say you know this is my
algorithms that I need to train and
that's actually where the data is and
this service is called machine learning
engine ml engine for friends we
basically take this code and
automatically train it by actually
spawning the necessary machines on the
back end so this was very useful because
again you don't have to care about how
many machine I have here or there and
actually kind of spawning up the
machines with the right environments so
did actually were the main basic tools
now of course as part of this those
researchers and actually this is
actually one thing actually I care a lot
in terms of people understanding they
loaded into Google cloud a lot of like
open source code and kind of scientific
libraries that they found useful for
their work
and these actually is the cool thing I
mean you don't have to think about okay
I have to do this work on Google cloud
so I'm going to kind of let go all the
tools that I'm familiar with and I kind
of get to learn all these other tools
and maybe you know Google cloud is not
made for astrophysics or chemical
research it doesn't involve a complete
reset of your careers okay obviously
people want to know okay this sounds
great can you point to some concrete
results I mean you know has the Google
cloud published a paper
it's the Nobel Prize I'm ready calling
up I mean maybe maybe the cloud is gonna
get to go to Sweden yes first of all I
mean like one thing actually want to
kind of make sure it's clear is that
these were actually researchers working
for this program and actually there are
actual researchers that work in very
often in universities they're usually
kind of post graduate students or
postdocs or some actually assistant
professor that was mentoring so as
Google Cloud we're not gonna publish a
paper those researchers will be and
there are a few actually are coming down
the line
in terms of concrete results I kind of
I'll mention a couple of things the
first one is on the exoplanet search
research the team actually was able to
train a model to recognize those planets
inside the Kepler data sets and then
actually we simulated that data set for
tests so again as I said at the
beginning we don't have yet the test
data so we couldn't run it there but we
simulated a data set from test NASA has
a very very sophisticated simulation of
what test data would look like and and
they were able to train a model on that
that on one side is more accurate at
least in percentages than what we know
are the accuracies from the previous
models that have been attempted
including the one from Google ai that I
was mentioning before and including
actually the human performance that is
currently estimated that is astronomer
kind of looking at the data so the model
was more accurate and I think actually
that was kind of course a great result
but to me actually even more exciting
the model ended up being a couple of
orders of magnitudes smaller than the
previous attempts of models that is it's
a very small model it's very compact and
what this allows is now actually to
consider kind of run in this in line
with data collection because before
actually a lot of those
those actually were pretty heavy and
they required a lot of like kind of
computation so they couldn't have been
run kind of as did it arrived being able
to run a model as they derive kind of
opens up a number of possibilities for
example what I mentioned before if there
is actually a particular detection on
test data as basically the data set is
getting extreme it means actually you
can now alert other telescopes or other
researchers about that potential
detection and it means actually
collecting other data from maybe kind of
other sources that could confirm or deny
that particular plan or maybe kind of
extract other characteristics and one of
the thing that I mentioned the beginning
is that test actually will only look at
a patch of the sky for 28 days one
limitation of this and then this
actually is not completely true because
there is a patch where they look
actually for an entire year
but in those patches you only kind of
get to see planets they have very very
short orbits right because the planet
has to go around
interplan and exactly and you know
sometimes you could see a transit but
then you need to get to see the second
transitive to come around because it's
taking too long but this actually could
be like great candidates for example for
NASA to now kind of say hey we have this
potential kind of candidates of planets
we don't know a what are the real
planets or not B how long it will take
to reach transit again and maybe we can
have you know again season in science
maybe or other telescope or other
researchers taken on that and kind of
augment the test data sets ma see me
clearly this is kind of revolutionary
maybe I should excise the words kind of
right this revolution I mean it seems
that were the the beginning where we've
opened the door to a whole new way of
analyzing data and learning things about
the cosmos but about nature in general
you know have we kind of reached the
tipping point you this is philosophical
but you figured that you know five
hundred years so now people will look
back at the beginning of the 21st
century and say the most important thing
that happened then was not reality
television it was it was the beginning
of a I applied to real world problems I
think actually this is really kind of
where the tipping point where where
these actually may happen I could
actually tell you that again
and I work in in AI
much brother if you want kind of a
spectrum of things than science itself
AI is changing a lot of the way in which
we think about problems and science is
one of the problem that we as human
think of probably one of the most
important one because it's about
understanding our universe in ourself
but AI is really kind of at a tipping
point where if you want it's now
starting to lead to results where we can
now solve problems in a very very
different way now for Sciences in
particular I think going back I don't
know in 500 years but but going back we
could really see that you know starting
from the 90s and then kind of in the
last two decades more and more kind of
if you want computers have been applied
to science I mean they go back I mean
the initial computers were almost
developed for science but now actually
is becoming so prominent that kind of
the idea of doing science without
computers is completely preposterous
today and I think actually in a few
decades it may be that the idea of doing
science without a I would be as
preposterous as today is the idea of
doing science without computers but what
about doing science without the
scientists I mean how far can this go
this actually is an interesting point
I'll tell actually kind of an enacted on
this so during the one of the final
review front technical reviews that we
had with the frontier development lab
would FDL were actually a number of life
course NASA researchers no professor and
we I mean the team's actually were
showing some of those results made with
AI and the reaction of questions about
well I mean like if this AI is
predicting so for example there was one
study a few about predicting kind of
solar activity and actually where they
would actually be able to predict much
better than the physical models that the
scientist had created for that and one
question is that well I mean like this
thing is predicting better than we are
doing but it's not really explaining
what is going on and at the end of the
day I mean in science we want to
understand the mechanism we want to
understand the physics behind it
so I think actually did I mean at least
in the spectrum of what we know today of
what the eye is doing there is a lot of
space for scientists because eventually
kind of these tools will simulate a lot
of data will may actually be able to
detect patterns may be able to kind of
if you want kind of refine that assets
in way that we're not able to do as
scientists as
humans but at the end of the day we also
want to I mean science is really about
understanding the why is is that really
kind of going back to that kind of
physical law or like understand actually
the mechanism what you're talking about
inside here right I mean Newton didn't
have AI working for him yet his brain
and it turned out that was good enough
to understand many of the but he didn't
have huge datasets right he didn't he
had very limited Tate it says now let it
take a field such as well you you know a
lot about that's neuroscience right they
they said the most complex thing in the
universe is the human brain I just may
be an insult to the Klingons but you
know say and I suppose that at the you
know very small level where you have you
know individual neurons and so forth and
synapses and all that stuff that you
might understand the chemistry you might
understand the physics of what's going
on there but that doesn't mean that you
understand how thinking works because
that's very complex this sounds like a
perfect application of this new
technology but will it provide indeed
the understanding of what happens or
does it just give you a model and you
you know you just input a lot of data
now you can tell what the next thought
is yeah I mean this goes through what I
was saying before it is right actually
you could I mean there are there are
applications of AI believe in
neuroscience as well where they would
actually start predicting she wouldn't
Neuros does or like what actually group
of neuro does however it doesn't explain
necessarily how that works so I think
again that's again it goes a little bit
into philosophy it's it's a very
important thing that today actually we
don't get to do we they I however in the
context of brain I think it's even more
if you want involved because I sense
what we're trying to do with the I in a
certain sense is to create artificial
intelligence that's what the word comes
about and one of the big questions about
the brain is what is intelligence how
does it work if you can actually create
alternate versions of intelligence let
me not have anything to do with how the
brain works right it still gives you a
lot of insights of what intelligence
could be or how intelligence could work
what are the limitations of intelligence
in certain areas or others so I think
actually for neuroscience I would say
there is the data part there is the
prediction part that is the same as it
but then the specific problem that you
solve when you study neuroscience or at
least one of the specific problems it's
very very close to what the essence of
artificial intelligence is and so that
sort of like you know a hundred years
ago a little more now when they were
trying to build flying machines
they tried at first to imitate birds you
know we'll have wings that flap and so
forth
that turned out not to be the right
approach right did they develop
something where the wings don't move at
all and you just have a big propeller in
the front that's not the way very few of
the birds in my backyard have propellers
right and yet they could make machines
that could fly pretty darn well but in
the end that actually gave them insights
into how birds fly so are you talking
about something like that will you build
a machine that you know can do some sort
of thinking process but it doesn't work
at all like the human brain but that
might be helpful if you want like a jet
engine it's not very similar to a bird
even if it has some kind of
characteristics and a helicopter is
completely different than a bird however
the principle they make things fly apply
and in a sense actually kind of if you
want if you go to the very kind of
bedrock of what flying is of how we
generate lift you can actually learn a
lot from birds but you can learn also
lot from helicopters and jet engines so
the idea here is that our brain is a way
of doing our intelligence and if you
build another way of doing intelligence
maybe by completely from means that may
actually still give you insights about
the bedrock what intelligence is and how
intelligence works now that's that I
would actually kind of just for the
public say that the most successful way
of doing AI today is deep learning and
it's based on this idea of neural
networks that a lot of like people that
as me actually have studied computation
your science will kind of say Oh neural
networks are very different from the
brain and it's true they're very very
different from the brain however they
have a lot of analogies and and those
analogies actually make aynd of give us
a hint about again that bedrock about
what intelligence is and how actually
you can build system to learn right
because it at the end of the day I mean
intelligence is a very kind of fuzzy
word but learning is something that we
are much more familiar with what I mean
Google did this experiment and what in
2012 I don't quite remember but they
took 16 thousand processors whatever
and they let it loose on the internet
and said go find something and it found
cats and with very high accuracy but I
don't like I mean it found cats probably
better than you know any cat could find
cat I don't know and you could say well
that's not very useful but of course the
fact that it could could see things on
the internet I mean so that's I guess
that's machine learning but I think a
lot of people regard all these
capabilities right the fact that if
you're a go play or a poker player or a
chess player you know there's a machine
that can beat you they regard them as a
threat and should we be looking at it
that way AI is that gonna take my job is
it going to destroy my lifestyle what's
your view up to my personal view on this
is that I think actually the one of the
greatest opportunity of of humanity so
actually I see it actually as it would a
very optimistic take I wouldn't work on
it if I wasn't very optimistic about it
that's that I think actually AI does
have dangers and that's I have questions
that we have to solve both you know in a
applicative way so like what are the
constraints where you want to apply and
also from a society perspective one
thing we we did at Google is that we
very recently this summer came out for
we're the first compared to really do
that come up with AI principles so we
have actually a code of conduct in terms
of where we think AI could be applied
and where it shouldn't and how it should
be applied when it's when it's there now
I personally don't think that this kind
of debate can only be in the realm of
operation like Google Google of course
has a lot of like invest investment
interest in AI but it's not the only
player here and I think actually we
should have more of a societal
discussion about it is that realistic
though I mean you know 99% of the world
agrees yes we have to have you know
these boundaries whatever but the one
percent that doesn't believe in that or
see some advantage to themselves and I
mean it sounds like they're there my
piece is you know kind of prominent kind
of researcher Nick Bostrom kind of
pointed out I is intrinsically
adversarial because to your point it
just takes 1% kind of to do the things
that they shouldn't do this is not very
dissimilar to other kind of dangerous
things
from nanotechnology biotechnology and
think like those but that sex is why
it's important to have that societal
discussion because I don't think
actually any corporation any institution
itself any zone actually can really kind
of put the right boundaries I think it's
really kind of is becoming more and more
kind of a humanity discussion and it's
interesting because we are in a point of
our history of our world where it seems
actually we're kind of getting more
fracture instead of kind of like anymore
United as like as a global kind of
humanity and and I see actually danger
in that on the other side this could be
things actually the kind of date unites
us because to your point I think the
majority of the people on earth would
agree on a number of of those things so
yeah well finally then my see I mean it
sounds like we're at a stage in the
development of technology here a kind of
analogous to the invention of the
microscope that telescope right these
were tools that allowed us to suddenly
make big discoveries it sounds like
you're saying that the 21st century in
the first half of the 21st century we
might see not only the detection of lots
of plants but life on those planets
maybe even intelligent life on those
plants and in medicine right though we
might be curing all sorts of diseases
that have stymied us for hundreds of
years and you know you wouldn't want to
rule out the tools I mean you want to
embrace those tools what's your advice
to you know young people are getting
interested in in science and technology
so again I think actually it's it's an
amazing time I mean I've always been
very passionate about science and
technology and you know like when I was
young it used to be that I mean unless
you are really lucky to go to a kind of
a good university and you have access to
libraries and journals you can't really
learn a lot of things nowadays I mean
young people can go on YouTube and kind
of watch like lessons of like the best
professors in the best universities for
free and this actually is kind of great
content you guys can play with things as
I said it doesn't take a lot of money
and by the way I mean they're also kind
of educational programs if you guys are
interested you know you can ping us at
Google cloud where we can actually give
you like credits but what I'm saying is
that it doesn't take much to get an even
do kind of serious science if you are
interested in it and I think actually
this actually democratize the science
enormously
and I'm really hoping that for the young
people that are listening to us that
they'll actually get actually the
passion for science in the right way
and now they have all the tools
literally kind of inside the laptop to
kind of go and do seriously it and I
think actually it is actually enlarges
the target population for scientists by
a number of order of magnitude from what
it used to be it sounds like we're
opening doors big doors yeah I think
people will have the motivation to walk
through
máximo Mascaro thanks so very much for
speaking with us i'm seth shostack thank
you for tuning in and we'll see you
another Google Facebook live thank you